joining me now is new york republican
congresswoman and member of the house
transportation and infrastructure
committee
and the house foreign affairs committee
nicole malliotakis she also serves as
the assistant whip for the house gop
congresswoman thank you for taking time
on this saturday you just heard our
reporter david spunt
at the white house on the latest about
the fauci
emails let me get your reaction to that
if i can
well you know as i was going through
some of the reporting on this
issue you may have noticed that the the
actual parts that talk about
the connection to the wuhan lab have
been redacted so first and foremost i
think we need to know what was in that
redacted
email that got that the fauci sent uh
when as it relates to rouhan now he
seems to be changing his
tune and now certainly is also calling
for a formal investigation and i do
believe look we need to have access to
the lab records
we need to know uh what those
individuals who did get sick in the fall
of 2019 who are scientists at the lab
need to know more about that uh because
they did display
the symptoms of provide and this is
something that representative scalise
representative jim jordan and i
have been advocating for a formal
investigation as
members of the subcommittee on
coronavirus it is shocking that the
democrats have not yet
brought forth a panel to actually have a
real discussion about this and the other
thing is
look america should be leading the way
but the international community must
also be advocating
for answers from the communist party of
china
that in itself uh the fact that you know
four
four million people died six hundred in
the united states a global community
could be demanding answers and we should
be holding funding
from the world health organization
unless they're going to get serious
about
transparency and holding the chinese
party chinese communist party
accountable
certainly a lot of questions about
whether we might get those
answers from china but do you anticipate
getting testimony from dr fauci on the
hill
we should absolutely breed bringing him
in we've already written to speaker
pelosi
uh demanding that she she call a hearing
on this issue
both the covid subcommittee as well as
the oversight committee
we must investigate this further we
should be questioning dr
fauci we should be questioning the ceo
of the eco health that provided grants
uh to to the wuhan lab federal dollars
that went over there
uh we we should be doing whatever we can
as american officials
to get answers for the american people
speaking of doing enough i want to just
switch gears a little bit we got the
friday jobs report yesterday and the
chairman of the dnc
putting out a statement applauding the
jobs report and then
also taking aim specifically at
republican members of congress
like yourself here is the statement the
dnc chair
put out saying that as each day passes
it becomes more clear that congressional
republicans
made a callous decision to turn their
backs
on struggling families and businesses
when they needed
help the most that a shot from jamie
harrison directly
at republicans for not doing enough to
advance the president's agenda your
reaction
you know in joe biden's words that is
complete malarkey
uh what i'll say is that as anything
uh the democrats have actually been
impediment to our
full recovery you have 100 million
americans that are currently on the
sidelines while small businesses are
desperate to get people back to work
and the reason that is is because
they've decided to give individuals
more money to stay home than to actually
report back to their workplace
that is completely irresponsible and
quite frankly
uh once those mandates those arbitrary
restrictions like governors like mine
governor cuomo had put in place were
lifted we knew that those jobs were
going to come back
so to try to take credit for that for
flicking on a light switch
uh is really really disingenuous of
course we always wanted to provide
aid and support to our small businesses
and those who were suffering
but that was not what this recovery
package just did
they put in all sorts of additional
spending that is going to hurt our
nation
is already hurting us when you look at
the the lack of labor
available because people are getting
paid won't stay home when you look at
the amount of products that are less
available on the market because of that
labor shortage
the supply chain interrupted and the
cost of goods are going up inflation yep
food
gas everything is going up and it's a
result of those policies put in place by
the democrats
congresswoman we're out of time we've
got to leave it there just a quick
short answer the negotiations seem
stalled but continue on infrastructure
do you think a deal will be reached next
week
i'm hopeful there's still talks going
our house committee on transportation
will be taking up a bill
on wednesday but it seems as long as we
focus on real infrastructure we can have
a deal absolutely
all right congresswoman nicole
malliotakis thank you for taking time on
this saturday
thank you